[Aplausos]
[Música]
actualmente hay unos 25 países sin
ejército amigos os hago una pregunta
cuál fue el primero qué país creéis que
fue el primero en renunciar a las
fuerzas armadas lo siento pero es
evidente que no fue un país europeo sino
un país latinoamericano costa rica
[Música]
el 1 de diciembre de 1948 tras una
guerra civil bajo la administración del
presidente josé figueres ferrer o costa
rica puso punto y final a su carrera
militar y sabéis que la apuesta no le
salió precisamente mal
[Música]
desde entonces el país no ha sufrido
ninguna guerra ni tampoco ningún golpe
de estado de hecho costa rica tiene en
su haber ser el país con el periodo
ininterrumpido de gobiernos democráticos
más largo de toda américa latina'
y es que amigos no nos olvidemos del
enorme peso que la bota militar ha
tenido tradicionalmente en latinoamérica
ni tampoco que este país costa rica se
encuentra situado en una de las regiones
más violentas del mundo
centroamérica
[Música]
pues bien a pesar de ello amigos este
país tropical que está localizado entre
el mar caribe y el océano pacifico ha
conseguido convertirse en un país de
renta media y disfrutar de unos niveles
de prosperidad bastante altos la receta
prosperidad paz y seguridad
estos son amigos los ingredientes que
han hecho que habitualmente el país tico
costa rica se ha conocido como la subida
de latinoamérica ahora bien que hay de
verdad en todo esto en este vídeo vamos
a tratar de conocer un poquito mejor a
costa rica vamos a echar un vistazo a
sus luces y también a sus sombras
veámoslo
[Música]
la cara alegre miremos por donde miremos
costa rica es un país muy especial
hablamos amigos de un país que tiene el
color verde como seña de identidad y es
que si de algo es sinónimo costa rica-
es precisamente de biodiversidad
veréis con una superficie casi 10 veces
más pequeña que la de españa o 25 veces
más pequeña que la de perú se calcula
que este país tiene en su territorio más
del 5 por ciento de toda la
biodiversidad mundial esto es de
animales y plantas y ojo aquí entienden
que esto no es sólo una seña de
identidad sino también potencialmente
una gran ventaja competitiva
por ejemplo entre otras cosas puede
servir para desarrollar una industria
turística diferenciada y de alto valor
añadido o para posicionar algo así como
una marca país que sea sugestiva es
decir que atribuya a los productos
locales un valor superior para el
consumidor internacional
[Música]
al fin y al cabo quien no estaría
dispuesto a pagar un poquito más por
productos que pensáramos lo que no
quiere decir que sea exactamente así que
se producen de forma limpia en un
entorno paradisíaco y ojo amigos porque
los que están riqueño se toman estas
políticas muy pero que muy en serio
costa rica quiere ser una potencia
ecológica así que dicho y hecho hoy más
del 25 por ciento del territorio
nacional está protegido y la inmensa
mayor parte de la electricidad procede
de fuentes renovables energía
hidroeléctrica geotérmica eólica y no
sólo eso costa rica es el único país de
la región y uno de los pocos del mundo
que ha conseguido revertir la
deforestación el territorio cubierto por
bosques ha pasado del 21 por ciento en
1987 a más del 50 por ciento actualmente
algo que por cierto se ha conseguido
gracias a un curioso sistema de pagos
por servicios ambientales veréis me
explico en costa rica una parte de los
impuestos sobre los carburantes van a
parar al fondo para el financiamiento
forestal de costa rica- un fondo que
retribuye a los propietarios de las
fincas y bosques que voluntariamente
quieren adherirse al programa eso sí por
conservar el espacio natural y poner en
marcha proyectos que ayuden a su
fortalecimiento
ojo no sólo eso muchas empresas también
contribuyen a este fondo para compensar
su impacto sobre el medio ambiente algo
así como una responsabilidad social
corporativa promovida por el estado
y aquí se abre un debate muy interesante
para unos estoy seguro estas políticas
eran una monstruosidad para otros una
forma de reconocer la externalidad
negativa que tiene en la actividad
productiva por ejemplo la contaminación
de las fábricas y también claro las
externalidades positivas de las áreas
naturales tenemos la mitad de nuestro
territorio cubierto de bosque y un
amplio sistema de áreas protegidas que
no solo resguarda parte importante de la
biodiversidad del planeta sino que da
sustento a sectores importantes de
nuestra economía como en el caso del
turismo carlos alvarado presidente de
costa rica
personalmente amigos creo que si este
tipo de iniciativas van acompañadas ojo
algo que frecuentemente se olvida de
políticas que promuevan la creación de
empresas y nuevos tipos de negocio creo
que pueden tener mucho éxito pero
abramos debates decirnos qué pensáis en
los comentarios pero continuemos
el caso es que este tipo de
planteamientos políticos no parecen
haber estado reñido con el crecimiento
económico fijaos desde el año 2000 la
economía costa rica ha crecido en torno
al 4% anual que aunque no parezca mucho
ha sido un crecimiento medio mayor que
el del resto de latinoamérica y también
que el crecimiento de los países de la
ocde
pero no sólo eso con costa rica pasa
algo similar a lo que ya vimos con el
caso de nueva zelanda si tomamos más
variables de medición además del pib
por ejemplo la esperanza de vida los
salarios la situación de las empresas
etcétera etcétera entonces costa rica-
sale mejor paradas
podemos echar un vistazo al índice
legatum de prosperidad y al ranking de
países por pib per cápita en paridad de
poder adquisitivo es decir teniendo en
cuenta la diferencia de precio
pues bien de esta forma vemos que aunque
el pib per cápita de costa rica es el
sexto de latinoamérica es decir está por
debajo de chile panamá uruguay argentina
y méxico y el 76º en el mundo en el
índice de prosperidad global costa rica
asciende hasta la plaza vigesimonovena
siendo el segundo país de latinoamérica
tan solo detrás de uruguay y a muy poca
distancia de él
queréis una prueba pues mirad la
esperanza media de vida en costa rica es
la tercera mayor de todo el continente
americano y es superior por ejemplo a la
de los mismísimos eeuu
[Música]
amigos costa rica parece un país
próspero pacífico y comprometido con la
preservación del medio ambiente suena
bien verdad pues espera un momento
porque el país también tiene otra cara
costa rica se enfrenta a retos
complicados atentos
[Música]
retos que amenazan al país
costa rica es un país que ha conseguido
grandes cosas sobre todo si lo
comparamos con muchos de sus vecinos sin
embargo en estos momentos ojo se
enfrenta a retos políticos económicos y
sociales que amenazan su camino a la
prosperidad el primero de ellos
claramente tiene mucho que ver con la
economía veréis aunque costa rica ha
tenido un sólido desempeño aún tiene
mucho camino por recorrer actualmente su
pib per cápita es sólo algo superior al
40 por ciento del promedio de los países
de la ocde y aquí hay problemas el
último gobierno ha sido como decirlo un
poquito irresponsable con la política
fiscal y ha dejado a costa rica en una
situación delicada fijaos tan sólo los
últimos diez años la deuda pública se ha
más que doblado en términos de pib el
déficit de 2018 se acercará ni más ni
menos que al 7 por ciento y uno de cada
tres dólares de gasto público se destina
ya precisamente al servicio de la deuda
uno de cada tres dólares mientras que en
el 2008 los impuestos financiaban el 70
por ciento de todos los gastos del
gobierno central ya en el 2017 sólo
alcanzaban para financiar el 50 por
ciento siendo necesariamente cubierta la
diferencia por medio del endeudamiento
jorge corrales que salga por fortuna
parece haber consenso político de no
en esta situación costa rica podría
enfrentarse a muchos problemas y cuidado
porque centrarse sólo en subir impuestos
puede ser contraproducente por ejemplo
el impuesto sobre los beneficios
empresariales de este país es ya uno de
los más altos del mundo y no son sólo
los impuestos también por ejemplo el
coste de la electricidad y de los
carburantes que están en manos de
monopolios públicos y entre los más
caros de la región lo que evidentemente
afecta a la competitividad del país
por cosas como estas la tasa de
participación laboral la tasa de gente
que trabaja es bastante baja señor
presidente señor carlos alvarado abra la
economía permita la competencia y a ser
posible marque un camino para repartir
la propiedad de las grandes empresas
públicas entre los costarriqueño
el segundo reto tiene que ver con la
violencia en los últimos años ha crecido
bastante en un país que tradicionalmente
ha sido muy seguro y muy tranquilo y
tiene una explicación
los narcos sí desgraciadamente lo
sabemos los narcos están asolando buena
parte de centroamérica y ahora tratan de
extender su influencia a costa rica que
no deja de ser una vía de paso para su
mercancía y tercero bueno el tercer reto
tiene mucho que ver con la política las
últimas elecciones han sido un buen
ejemplo de como mensajes radicales y
populistas que ponen en la diana las
libertades civiles son un peligro
veréis la primera vuelta electoral
celebrada en febrero no la ganó carlos
alvarado sino fabricio alvarado un
pastor evangelista con un discurso muy
radical entre sus obsesiones está
perseguir cualquier modelo de sociedad
diferente al que él concibe como
conveniente especialmente todo lo
referente con el matrimonio igualitario
y ojo uno puede tener la confesión que
quiera y plantear su vida como le dé la
gana pero cuando un político pretende
que el gobierno se dedique a la religión
y a perseguir a quienes no están de
acuerdo con su modelo de vida eso es un
peligro aquí tenéis al aura mosco a la
mujer de fábrica alvarado en plena
campaña no me digáis que no asusta y el
espíritu santo viene con interpretación
damasco ha visto colocó que en dar a
mamá más sé que era macho a autónomos o
cantar ama que haga más se catarán por
fortuna en la segunda vuelta este pastor
evangelista cuyo discurso tiene mucho de
odio y poco de amor sufrió una derrota
aplastante pero aún así se hizo con el
30 por ciento de los votos cuidado con
la tendencia amigos así están las cosas
carlos alvarado acaba de ser elegido
presidente en su mano está lograr que
costa rica- recupere el buen camino para
lograrlo va a tener que cambiar muchas
cosas y no olvidar que la mejor forma de
combatir la pobreza es impulsando
economías más dinámicas abiertas y
competitivas la empresa tendrá que jugar
sí o sí un papel destacado en todo este
proceso
pero ahora turno para ti crees que costa
rica es una referencia a seguir déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo no te
olvides de darle a like y suscribirte
abisal político si aún no lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]